En otros videos hablamos de la noción de la teoría
cinética molecular, que simplemente escribiré como
TCM, y la idea es que si imaginas un contenedor
-lo dibujaré en dos dimensiones aquí- que contiene
algo de gas, puedes imaginar el gas como estas
partículas, donde su volumen colectivo es mucho
más pequeño que el volumen del contenedor, y la
temperatura aquí está relacionada con la energía
cinética promedio de las partículas. Todas estas
partículas se están moviendo y deslizándose, por
lo que cada una tiene algo de energía cinética.
Recuerda que la energía cinética se calcula como
MV²/2. Entonces, cada una de estas partículas
tiene algo de masa y algo de velocidad, pero es
probable que todas tengan velocidades diferentes,
incluso si son del mismo tipo de partícula;
y si son diferentes tipos de partículas también
pueden tener diferentes masas, pero el promedio de
las energías cinéticas de todas estas partículas
es proporcional a la temperatura medida en Kelvin
Y la presión, recuerda que la presión no es más
que la fuerza por unidad de área. Entonces puedes
imaginar esta superficie del contenedor, que puede
ser algún tipo de cubo, así que puedo dibujarlo
en tres dimensiones. Así que hay un área aquí y
tenemos a las partículas -permíteme dibujar esto
en un color diferente-. Estas partículas rebotan
constantemente. Hay muchas más partículas aquí de
las que puedo dibujar, así que en todo momento
estas partículas rebotan en todos los lados del
recipiente. Estas son colisiones perfectamente
elásticas que conservan la energía cinética,
por lo que todas ellas ejercen algo de fuerza al
rebotar colectivamente en esta área, por lo que la
presión se debe a la fuerza de las colisiones
de las partículas en la superficie. Ahora,
lo que quiero hacer en este video es tomar
estas ideas de la teoría cinética molecular,
y a partir de ellas entender por qué tiene sentido
la Ley de los gases ideales, que es PV = nRT. Y
como recordatorio: P es expresión, V es volumen, n
es la cantidad de moles del gas que nos interesa,
la cantidad de ese gas, T es la temperatura en
Kelvin y R es la constante de los gases ideales,
simplemente es una constante para que todas
las unidades funcionen juntas. Entonces,
primero pensemos en cómo se relaciona la
presión con el volumen si mantenemos todo
lo demás constante. Bueno, la idea de la Ley de
los gases nos dice que la presión multiplicada
por el volumen será igual a esto si lo mantenemos
constante. Puedo escribir una k aquí para indicar
que es una constante, pero también significa que
podríamos dividir ambos lados entre V. Podemos
decir que la presión es igual a alguna constante
entre V. Otra forma de pensar en esto es que la
presión es proporcional al inverso del volumen,
y si dividimos ambos lados entre P podemos
escribir esto como el volumen es proporcional
al inverso de la presión. ¿Tiene sentido esto
desde el punto de vista de la teoría cinética
molecular? Pausa este video y piénsalo. Bueno,
imagina nuestro cubo original aquí, que tiene
el mismo número de partículas, y éstas tienen
la misma energía cinética promedio pero digamos
que queremos aumentar el volumen. Entonces, si
tengo que aumentar el volumen tengo que expandir
esto de alguna manera, o quizá poner exactamente
el mismo número de partículas y con la misma
temperatura en un recipiente más grande. Entonces,
en un momento dado, las partículas rebotan menos
en las superficies del contenedor ya que tienen
más espacio para moverse en ese volumen; también
será mayor el área superficial del contenedor,
por lo que tiene sentido que, si aumenta el
volumen, baje la presión. También puedes pensar
en esto de otra forma. Si haces esto más pequeño,
pero se tiene la misma cantidad de partículas con
la misma energía cinética promedio, simplemente
rebotarán contra las paredes del contenedor con
mayor frecuencia, por lo que aumentará la presión.
Así que cuando el volumen disminuye, la presión
aumenta. A esta relación inversamente proporcional
entre la presión y el volumen, si se mantiene todo
lo demás constante, se le conoce como Ley de
Boyle. Ahora veamos otra relación. ¿Qué pasa
entre la presión y la temperatura si mantienes
constante el volumen y el número de moles? Bueno,
si mantienes constante esto, esto y esto, la Ley
de los gases ideales nos indica que la presión
va a ser proporcional a la temperatura, o que la
temperatura será proporcional a la presión. ¿Esto
tiene sentido? Regresemos al contenedor original.
Si la temperatura aumenta, eso significa que la
energía cinética promedio aumenta, por lo que
estas partículas al rebotar en el costado del
contenedor lo golpearán con más velocidad.
Esto quiere decir que en cualquier momento
dado ejercerán mayor presión en ese costado
del contenedor. Y ahora veamos lo contrario. Si
disminuyes la temperatura, la energía cinética
va a disminuir, por lo que las partículas se
desplazarán más despacio. Esto hace que disminuya
la velocidad con la que estas partículas rebotan
en el costado del contenedor haciendo que
la presión disminuya, por lo que esto tiene
sentido por completo: si aumenta la temperatura,
aumenta la presión y si la temperatura disminuye,
la presión también disminuirá. Esto se conoce como
la Ley Gay-Lussac. Bien, analicemos otra relación,
y sí, estamos analizando todas las combinaciones
posibles. ¿Qué pasaría si mantenemos constantes
la presión y el número de moléculas? Bueno, pues
en realidad estamos analizando la relación entre
el volumen y la temperatura. Nuevamente, si P, n
y R se mantienen constantes, la Ley de los gases
ideales nos dice que el volumen es proporcional
a la temperatura, así que, para analizar esto,
vamos a repetir el experimento mental que
acabamos de hacer. Si aumentamos la temperatura
estas partículas se moverán más rápido, y si
queremos mantener constante la cantidad de
fuerza por área en los costados del contenedor,
entonces tenemos que aumentar el volumen. Por lo
que vemos que esta relación es completamente
consistente con la teoría cinética molecular
y se conoce como Ley de Charles. Otra relación
a analizar es la relación entre el volumen y el
número de moles. Si se mantiene constante todo lo
demás, la Ley de los gases ideales nos dice que el
volumen es proporcional al número de moles de la
partícula o del gas que nos interesa. Esto tiene
sentido porque, de nuevo, si mantienes constante
todo lo demás, que la presión sea constante,
que la temperatura sea constante, y si yo quiero
duplicar el número de partículas aquí, pero no
quiero que cambie la presión y la temperatura,
tiene sentido que tenga que duplicar el volumen.
Del mismo modo, si quiero duplicar el volumen y
no quiero que cambien la presión y temperatura,
tengo que agregar el doble de partículas aquí,
para mantener el número de interacciones o rebote
de partículas en el costado del contenedor, y que
la presión se mantenga constante. A esta relación
se le llama Ley de Avogadro. Y, por último,
pero no menos importante, imagina que tienes dos
contenedores idénticos, uno está aquí y el otro
está acá, y voy a dibujar un tercer contenedor
aquí. Imagina que tienes el gas número 1. En
este caso tienes algo de presión debido al gas 1,
vamos a suponer que los tres contenedores tienen
el mismo volumen y temperatura. Ahora imagina que
tienes el gas número 2, que también ejerce
cierta presión. Si tuvieras que tomar ambos
gases y ponerlos juntos en el tercer contenedor,
entonces el tercer contenedor tendrá todo el gas 1
y todo el gas 2, pero sin cambiar su volumen ni su
temperatura. Así que en cualquier unidad de área
en la superficie del contenedor habrá colisiones
de las partículas del gas 1, lo que te da P₁ en
esa fuerza por unidad de área, y también habrá
colisiones de las partículas del gas 2, lo que
te da esta otra fuerza por unidad. Entonces, tiene
sentido que las presiones parciales se sumen para
crear la presión total del recipiente. Esto se
conoce como Ley de Dalton. El objetivo de este
video es que aprecies que lo que hemos estado
hablando en relación con la Ley de los gases
ideales tiene mucho sentido cuando lo analizamos
en el contexto de la teoría cinética molecular.